One way to solve this is to define a variable called change and set it equal to tolerance,
where tolerance is a parameter in our function, and you can see its default value is very, very small.
And, as long as this change is greater than or equal to tolerance,
we're going to initialize change to zero,
and iterate over not quite every entry in the path.
You can see here that we want to exclude the first and last entries.
And so, for each entry, we're going to
set an aux variable equal to the new path value at that entry,
we're going to increment newpath, where these are the equations from gradient descent,
we're going to increment change by however much this newpath has changed in this step,
and we're going to keep doing this and doing this
until change becomes less than tolerance, at which point
we can return our new path.
And we see if we run this, we go from this right-angle, jerky path
to this nice, smooth path taking us from [0,0] to [4,4].